.
>> Laura: THIS IS THE INGRAHAM
ANGLE FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
LET THE MELT DOWN BEGIN.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
THEY'RE DESPERATE, I'M TELLING
YOU DESPERATE TO FIND ANY EDGE
ON REPUBLICANS AS MIDTERMS
APPROACH.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THIS HIDEOUS
ATTACK ON PAUL PELOSI IN THEIR
SAN FRANCISCO HOME, OF COURSE WE
HOPE AND PRAY FOR HIS FULL
RECOVERY FROM THIS DISGUSTING
ATTACK, THE QUESTION IS WILL
DEMOCRATS ATTEMPT TO USE THE
ACTIONS OF LONE LUNATICS TO
CHILL POLITICAL SPEECH?
IF SO THIS IS BECAUSE THEIR GRIP
ON POWER IS GIVING WAY ON TWO
MAJOR FRONTS TONIGHT.
IN POLITICS AND ACROSS SOCIAL
MEDIA.
FOR THEM, ELON MUSK'S SUCCESSFUL
PURR WHICH YOU SAY OF TWITTER IS
A TOTAL INVASION OF THEIR
INTER-SANCTUMS LIKE AN INTRUDER
WALTZING INTO THEIR LIVING ROOM
AND MAYBE MAKING A SANDWICH AND
TURNING ON FOX NEWS AND USING
THE BATHROOM.
HOW DARE HE.
MOST REGULAR PEOPLE SEE ELON'S
DESIRE TO HOUSE CLEAN AT TWITTER
AS PLAIN COMMON SENSE.
AFTER ALL, WE DISCOVERED THERE'S
A LOT OF FAT TO CUT L.
>> WELCOME TO A DAY IN MY LIFE
AS A TWITTER EMPLOYEE.
>> THEN MAKE MY WAY DOWN TO THE
LOG CABIN AREA.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS BUT IT
WAS COOL.
PLAYED FUSE BALL WITH MY FRIENDY
FRIENDS TO UNWIND A BIT AND IT
WAS COOL.
THEN GOING TO THE MEDITATION
ROOM THAT I THOUGHT WAS SUPER
NEAT.
I HAD RED WINE THAT'S ON TAP.
>> Laura: IN IS THE CULTURE
THE LEFT IS DESPERATE TO
PROTECT.
A PRIVATE CLUB FOR SUPREMELY
ENTITLED RATHER DITSY AND
SELF-SATISFIED LIBERALS AND IT'S
NOT ENOUGH TO CONTROL THE
WASHINGTON JOURNAL, NEW YORK
POST AND ALL OF HOLLYWOOD AND
EVERY MAJOR UNIVERSITY.
THE FACT THAT THEY WANT TO
VILIFY ANYONE WHO DISAGREES WITH
THEM INCLUDING THIS NETWORK WITH
MUSK HIMSELF SHOWS THEIR CLAIMS
TO CARE ABOUT DEMOCRACY OR FREE
SPEECH WERE ALWAYS SPECIOUS.
THEY TRULY DON'T KNOW HOW TO
DEAL WITH THE PLEUROISTIC
SOCIETY IN WHICH OTHER PEOPLE
HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS JUST LIKE
THEY DO ANY TIME A CONSERVATIVE
ARRIVES TO THE COLLEGE CAMPUS.
>> [ CHANTING "HATE HAS NO HOME
HERE"].
>> Laura: NOW, THEY MAY ALL
FEEL PROTECTED ON CAMPUS BY ALL
THE WOKESTERS AND TURNS OUT IT'S
FALLING APART AND THE LEFT AND
THE CONTROL WERE WRONG ABOUT
JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING.
THIS WEEK THE MEDIA REGIME
FINALLY STARTED TO NOTICE.
>> DEMOCRATIC STRATEGISTS ARE
CONCERNED.
AND ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE PARTY
IS HAVING TROUBLE IN POLLING
LEADING UP TO THE MIDTERMS AND
MORE ON WITH ANOTHER GROUP.
GENX LEADING AWAY FROM
DEMOCRATS.
>> DEMOCRAT'S MESSAGES ROE V
WADE AND FEAR OF LOSING
DEMOCRACY, WHICH ARE TWO
MONSTROUS THINGS TO TALK ABOUT
ARE NOT BUCKING WHAT PEOPLE FEEL
AS THEY GO TO THE GAS PUMPS.
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE.
THEY'RE NOT THE KITCHEN TABLE
ISSUES BUT THEY'RE THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUES OVER TIME.
>> Laura: DON'T YOU GET IT
PEOPLE, YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO CARE
ABOUT THAT AND FRIENDS THEY PUSH
TO KEEP MS. HOCHUL IN OFFICE
POURING MILLIONS INTO LAST
MINNESOTA ADS AND BEDROCK OF
BLACK AND LATINO VOTERS MIGHT
NOT TURN OUT.
THEY'RE TURNING OUT FOR WHAT?
HIGH CRIME?
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE VOTING
FOR.
THE TRUTH IS WE NOW HAVE CLOSE
SENATE IN PLACES LIKE MINNESOTA,
WASHINGTON STATE, OREGON, EVEN
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE AND DEMOCRATS
NEVER THOUGHT IT'S GOTTEN SEATS
L. MEANWHILE GOVERNOR ABBOTT AND
TEXAS DESANTIS AND MORE IN
GEORGIA UP DOUBLE DIGITS OVER
THEIR RIVALS AND THE TRUTH IS
GETTING TOO HARD FOR THE PRESS
TO AVOID.
DEMOCRAT POLICIES HAVE LEFT
AMERICANS POORER, OUR COUNTRY
WEAKER, AND WITH THE ADDED BONUS
OF TAKING US TO THE BRINK WITH
ALL OUT WAR WITH RUSSIA.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A HUGE
POLITICAL PRICE TO BE PAID FOR
THIS.
RATHER THAN TRYING TO TACK TO
THE MIDDLE, DEMOCRATS, THEY JUST
KEEP DIGGING THEMSELVES FURTHER
INTO A HOLE AND NOW POPULOUS
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE WHO IS ARE
BOLD AND WHO ARE BRAVE ARE ABOUT
TO BURY THEM.
THEY'RE TELLING THEMSELVES LIE
AFTER LIE FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND
INFLATION WAS TRANSITORY.
>> I SEE IMPORTANT TRANSITORY
INFLUENCES AT WORK.
I DON'T ANTICIPATE THAT WE'LL BE
PERMANENT.
>> MOST OF THE PRICE INCREASES
WE'VE SEEN ARE -- WERE EXPECTED
AND EXPECTED TO BE TEMPORARY.
IT'S NOT REGULAR INFLATION
ANYMORE.
I'M BRINGING IT DOWN. DOWN.
>> Laura: THEY SAID CRIME WAS
A REPUBLICAN TALKING POINT.
>> THERE'S A REAL CRIME PRIME
WE'RE ADDRESSING AND THOSE SIX
CRIMES.
>> Laura: THEIR PROPAGANDA
WOULD MEAN STUFF AND IT'S
CONCERNS AROUND THE RACEST
RHETORIC THAT GOES HAND IN GLOVE
WITH THE LAW AND ORDER MESSAGES
AND SOME REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES
ARE INTENTIONALLY LINKING RACE
AND CRIME AS A TACTIC TO
UNDERMINE THEIR BLACK OPPONENTS.
>> Laura: AND THEY BELIEVE
THAT PARENTS WOULDN'T KICK UP A
FUSS IN SCHOOL BOARD ELECTIONS.
EVEN WHEN SCHOOL BOARDS WERE
BEING DOMINATED BY RADICAL
GENDER ACTIVISTS.
>> I'VE LIVED IN LAUDEN COUNTY
MY ENTIRE LIFE AND CARE SO
DEEPLY ABOUT THIS COMMUNITY.
WE NEED A REPRESENTATIVE WHO
SHARES OUR VALUES AND WILL FIGHT
FOR OUR VALUES.
I'VE SEEN WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE SOMEONE ADVOCATING
FOR THOSE LEFT OUT OF THE ROOM.
>> NICK DOESN'T SEEM TO SHOW A
WHOLE LOT OF INTEREST IN
INCLUDING PARENTS IN THE
EQUATION BECAUSE HE SPECIFICALLY
STATED HE WOULD SUPPORT THE
POLICY THAT LEAVES PARENTS IN
THE DARK WHEN IT COMES TO
KNOWING WHAT NAMES THEIR
CHILDREN ARE USING IN SCHOOL OR
WHICH BATHROOM THEY'RE USING.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT NICK IS
BEING GENUINE IN HIS CONCERN
ABOUT PARENT INVOLVEMENT.
WHEN HE WANTS TO CUT THEM OUT OF
THE EQUATION.
>> NICK, WOULD YOU LIKE TO USE
30 SECONDS HERE?
>> NO, I'M GOOD.
>> Laura: NO, I'M GOOD.
WELL, OF COURSE ALL OF WHAT THE
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SAYING IS
FALSE.
NOW THE VOTERS ARE CATCHING UP
TO THE LIES.
BUT THE BIGGEST LIE OF ALL WAS
THAT THEY THERE WERE RED STATES
AND BLUE STATES.
LOOK, THERE'S THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
OBAMA SAID THAT; RIGHT, BACK IN
2004, WELL HE WAS RIGHT.
THAT MEANS POLITICAL LEADERS
CAN'T TAKE ANY STATE FOR
GRANTED, CAN'T WRITE ANY STATE
OFF OR LEAVE ANY STATE BEHIND.
AMERICANS "COAST-TO-COAST" ARE
TIRED, THEY'RE TIRED OF SEEING
STREETS CRAWLING WITH DRUGGIES
AND CRIMINALS AND THE SOUTHERN
BORDER TEAMING WITH ILLEGALS AND
TIRED OF SEEING 401KS CRATERING
AND TIRED OF PAYING $100 TO FILL
UP SUVS AND THE DRAG QUEENS
TWERKING IN FRONT OF LITTLE KIDS
AND TIRED OF HEARING COLLEGE
KIDS THAT ARE CODDLED LITTLE
SNOW FLAKES WINE ABOUT PRIVILEGE
AND MICRO-AGGRESSIONS AND A
RECKONING IS